we've been following the ted cruz
spectacle after he and his family snuck
away to cancun
while his state faced a crippling winter
storm that left millions without power
rightfully he was blasted with criticism
but fortunately
his new communications director came to
his defense
um yes senator cruz is in cancun right
now um but you know here at his offices
we say big look
senator cruz deserves to relax unwind
unplug recharge you know like you would
a power outlet
um or his power grid's going to go out
and we can't be having that
you know that's too important so he's
got to take care of his light which
comes from the inside
and um it's just like why can't he have
his love moment
like everybody else can it's just funny
to me it's funny that
whenever he's here in america and he's
doing his little jokes on twitter
everybody says go away ted we hate you
but then when he goes away to cancun
everybody says well where is ted
why isn't he doing his little jokes on
twitter now sometimes you just don't
know what you got till it's gone and
that should be a lesson
for the americans um wondering where
senator ted cruz is at this morning
it's a joke i repeat
it's a joke ted cruz's actual new comms
person is a former trump flack the video
you just saw
is of the brilliant comedian blair
erskine and that's just one of the
parodies
that's got millions of views and helped
her build quite a name for herself
in recent months and here's the real
thing the comedian herself
blaire eskin joins me now thank you so
much for coming on the show tonight
we're all very excited my entire team
we're very excited to hear you were
coming on the show tonight because we've
enjoyed your videos how did you get
started
making them did you ever imagine how
popular they'd become how many people
would be fooled by them
yeah oh thank you for having me first of
all i'm so excited to be here
um yeah this was a mistake it wasn't
supposed to happen this was never
supposed to happen
i started making them at the beginning
of lockdown
and um you know i was doing what i'm
doing now which is just making fun of
people in the news and my friends would
watch them and say ha ha this is funny
and i just that put me on top of the
world i was like oh 30 people think i'm
funny
um and then in july the uh the costco
guy went viral the guy who was like i
feel threatened
because someone asked him to wear a mask
and uh i was like i'm just gonna pretend
to be his wife
see what happens and and then this
happened and i've just been competing
with myself ever since
to see who else i could i could trick i
guess
did anyone from team cruz or the gop
reach out to you thinking you were real
no
i wanted them to i wanted to get a cease
and desist
but no no one acknowledged it at all it
was it was very disappointing it was
very disappointing
you mentioned you mentioned the costco
wife
uh from the guy who refused to wear a
mask let's play that for our viewers
have a listen
i know that a lot of y'all have seen uh
that video
of my husband dan asserting his american
rights and costco so
um i just really i just want to clear a
few things up about it okay
dan was not threatened in the costco i
know that he was like
i feel threatened i feel threatened but
he was not threatened at all he wasn't
scared at all were you babe no
no see i feel threatened is um it's
actually our family's crest so
we just say it sometimes like he said it
to me in our wedding vows you know he
was like i feel threatened
and i was like addy too ah well
do we know if this man even has a wife
how do you end up
choosing characters like that and others
i googled beforehand if he had a wife
and he didn't appear to have a wife uh
so i i just wanted to make sure that she
that was my first you know one of my
first videos and so i just wanted to
make sure i wasn't offending anyone now
i really don't care if they exist or if
they don't exist
uh but um you know the thing about
these republican men that i tend to make
fun of they don't really let their wives
or their daughters
speak like these women don't have voices
public voices at least
for example i i did a video about tom
cotton i pretended to be his wife and
i've tried to find a video online of
this woman speaking and she just doesn't
and so it's very easy to slip into those
characters and and just
make up a persona because they don't
know what they like at all
yeah yeah no one's ever no one's ever
heard the real deal
exactly i mean when i watched your ted
cruz thing i was like that could be a
ted cruz comms person it's not beyond
the realms that they would offer that
uh justification um one of the other
people you did is marjorie taylor
green's daughter let's have a listen to
that one
hey i know i made a video last week
saying that my mom margaret taylor green
isn't crazy and
i just want to apologize for that
because she is crazy she's not qualified
to be in congress
she shouldn't be in congress she should
be at an olive garden 10 minutes before
it closes ask him to speak to the
manager that's where he that
that's her natural habitat
and today after margarita posted a sign
and today after she posted a sign
outside of her office that read there
are two genders male and female trust
the science uh to that you tweeted
marjorie taylor green belongs in a used
car commercial yelling at people to come
by toyota's
is there a danger that yeah we laugh at
green and how mad and almost beyond
parody she is
but we did the same with trump and he
ended up becoming president
yeah yeah i do think there is a danger
um and i try to be aware of that
uh it's hard though whenever these
people are whenever she does anything
you know it's hard not to comment on it
but i think we do have to be aware of
the content we're putting out and what
we're saying about her because um
you're right that's how trump got into
office we didn't take him seriously and
then we just
you know used him as a punch line
basically and then look what happens so
but gosh it's hard not to make fun of
her when she does stuff like that my god
and you can tell she eats it up too
the oh yeah she's dead after 100 percent
she literally
is the worst yeah she exists
to troll i mean that's what she does the
own the libs i think is their
favorite phrase you grew up around
republicans i believe blair
how did you end up not just being a
progressive but deciding to target
republicans
uh with your humor and comedy
gosh i mean i think it's just that
that's what i grew up in and so it's
what i know
um it's you know it's kind of in my
blood these these women this persona
that i just slip into so easily it's
because i grew up in a very small
town very sort of baptist centric town
you know where these things were just
it's just second nature to me to make
fun of these people because i know them
i think that in order to make fun of
something you kind of have to have an
understanding
of that thing and i i unfortunately have
quite a deep understanding of these
types of people so
i think that's just you know i have
another friend kylie breakman who does a
great job of you know making fun of
liberals and
it's because she grew up in a town that
was full of liberals and so i think it's
just sort of
my background and it's it's kind of easy
for me i don't really have to reach
it's interesting you say you have a
friend who makes fun of liberals which
is fine there's lots to make fun of
liberals about
um but there is this debate right now
about quote-unquote conservative comedy
what is your view and the idea
you know you see parody sites like what
is it called babylon b trying to be the
onion and just it's not funny
and there's this argument from some that
just there is no conservative comedy
it's a contradiction
do you agree with that do you share that
view contentious view
yeah i i saw people i saw those think
pieces and i really did try to think of
a conservative comedian that i i found
funny or a comedian i guess that does
what i do right and they make fun of
um liberals but as a conservative and i
can't
i can't think of one and i don't know
what it is i think maybe
i try not to punch down too much like in
the characters i do i try to make
you know the women smarter than their
husbands or their fathers and kind of
turn it on its head and i feel like
maybe conservatives their go-to is to
just go straight for like the
you know gut punch and the not bullying
but i think
it's definitely more mean-spirited and
maybe that's why
i don't know i i read some babylon b
articles
and i didn't understand i i don't know
how that website exists there was one
about
aoc tying her shoe and it was like aoc
can't tie her shoe
because she's stupid and then somebody
wrote that piece that made it past
the editor and on so then or not i'll
never understand it
i never understand it conservative
comedy quote unquote are there any
topics or people that are off limits for
you you mentioned that
you republicans are the people you know
you grew up around them is there a
backlash are there
friends or family members you're worried
about offending
no not anymore not not friends or family
members i mean i say that but i did get
off facebook this year because i didn't
want to deal with them
with the backlash from these people i
grew up with so maybe there's a little
bit of a fear but
for the most part i don't i don't think
about that too much
my my family is pretty liberal for the
most part i mean i've got
plenty of conservative family members
but you know the people that love me
they love me
um as far as public figures i try not to
i i try not to um i don't know i try not
i don't want to hurt anyone's feelings
like there was a politician whose uh
daughter had died a few years ago and
someone was like play his daughter and
a fictional daughter you know but i'm
not trying to be a bully and
and tap into any trauma definitely so
that's where i draw the line i would say
well what you are doing we're enjoying
very much we're out of time but thank
you so much for joining us tonight to
talk about it we appreciate it blaire
skin
uh thank you for being on the show